We love crossword puzzles,
(audience applauding)
they're my favorite thing to do,
and you host the new crossword puzzle game show,
called "People Puzzler," and it's with People magazine.
This is freak out, amazing good,
and it's game show week here on our show,
so we thought it'd be fun to play "Drew's Clues."
(audience cheering)
Love it.
(uptempo cheery music)
Okay, all you've got to do is solve
our super simple crossword puzzles (laughs),
and you'll have 30 seconds to solve each category.
Now, if you get two out of three puzzles correct,
each of our BFFs will get a $100 gift cards
to the thermal apparel brand, HeatHolders.com,
and you get gloves, socks, hats,
you're gonna be warm and cozy.
Plus we're also gonna donate $5,000
to Leah's charity of choice, which is Feeding America.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
Are you good at crossword puzzles yourself?
I'm not really that great, only under pressure.
I mean, we play games here all the time,
I have a closet full of games.
My family is always here at my house, thank God,
but you know, it is very competitive here,
especially like games like Charades
where my mother still doesn't understand.
When I tell her if I do this, like it means film.
I mean, I don't know how else to explain it to you.
(all laughing)
I wanna be there during one of your Charades night.
Lots of fights, lots of fights,
just on getting the rules straight,
so, but timed crossword puzzles.
My brain just shuts down, but let's try it, let's go
Get that competitive spirit going, all right!
Get the freak out going.
Okay, okay.
(audience cheering)
(logo dinging)
All right, there's costars, dogs, and game shows.
Leah, pick your first category.
Dogs.
Perfect.
Perfect, I'm a dog person, okay (claps).
The clock starts now!
Okay, first down, first clue.
Okay.
The apparatus you use to walk your dog.
Leash.
Yes.
Okay, you bury it in the backyard.
Number two, number two.
Bone.
Yes, and number three
is I throw a ball, and you bring it back is?
Fetch.
Yes!
(audience applauding)
You guys, did see that?
Ready, ah, yes.
All right, pick your next category.
Costars.
(logo dinging)
Got it, okay, costars.
Okay, start the clock, here we go?
Okay, number one down (stammers),
the "Saved by the Bell" boyfriend.
Zack?
Yes!
(Drew stuttering)
Zack Morris?
Mark Paul?
Oh, oh, oh (stammers).
Paul Gosselaar, Paul--
Yes, yes, yes!
Your "Old School" hubby is "Look at the baby".
What?
The actor who's your "Old School" hubby?
Kevin James?
No, "Old School" the movie,
sorry.
Oh, oh, Vince Vaughn.
Yes, well done, that puzzle is out of time.
Okay, one more, we have one more chance to win.
Number three is the category of game shows.
Okay, number one down is a game show,
and the last host was Alex Trebek.
Jeopardy.
Thank you.
Okay, and number two across
is the blank show about couples.
The blank show about couples?
Bob Eubanks hosted it.
"The Newlywed Game?"
Yes, yes!
Okay, and next one three across, hosted by Jeff Probst.
"Survivor," "Survivor?"
Yes, yes, darn it!
(audience applauding)
Leah, you won,
which means we're giving a $100 gift card
to each of our BFFs, and $5,000 to Feeding America.
Thank you, thank you so much.
Thank you for that.
Thank you so much.
I literally like have to lay down now
that was so much anxiety.
I'm at home, I don't really need to win,
so you could only imagine how people feel
when they're doing these shows.
I have an ulcer.
(audience laughing)
I straight up have an ulcer.
It's like you go like blank,
and you wanna throw up when you're playing game shows.
And your brain just shuts down,
like your brain says, "I don't know it, I don't know it."
When you can know it,
like I go through this with my daughter.
I'm sure you go through this when you're doing work
with them, and they go, "I don't know, I don't know."
And you just go, "Just cal down, you do know it.
"You know these answers, just relax.
"Don't tell yourself you don't know," you know like that,
but that's what I did.
You were just so calming just now,
like I wanna be your daughter, I'm not kidding.
I was like listening to you, and you're like,
"You don't know," and the nails, they're like hypnotic,
and I'm like, "Yes."
(audience laughing)
Oh, thank you, Leah Remini.
I look forward to seeing you in person.
I love you, I wanna bring you some candy shoes.
Yeah, some Chemin de Fers (laughs).
Thank you so much.
You got it.
"People Puzzler" airs weeknights at 6:00 PM
on the Game Show Network.
(upbeat music)
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪